[Music]
you've seen good board game movies like
clue and like I guess that's about it
now get ready for a movie with more
scares than we G more quality than
Dungeons & Dragons and about a thousand
times more logic than battleship Mahalo
Oh Jumanji before you catch step 16 of
the rocks 25 point plan to rule the
world revisit the children's classic
that's way too scary for children and
scariest of all doesn't give Robin
Williams anything funny to say when the
Year the Clampetts have a yard sale ha
ha as this guy in a weird green costume
makes peace with the death of his
childhood one of mrs. niedelmeyer still
teaching sixth grade
in other words hook in Reverse get ready
to play Jumanji the vaguely African
board game that's ruined at least three
generations of kids lives where all you
have to do is roll the dice then read a
slight variation on move your ass party
better move staying put would be a
blunder stampede
guys stampede how many times does this
have to happen before you automatically
start running run finally geez meet Alan
Parrish a boy who was sucked into a
board game only to emerge as a confused
and hairy Robin Williams a hairy Robin
Williams now along with this traumatized
Playmate Sarah and two super unlucky
orphans they'll do whatever it takes to
finish the game they started 26 years
ago just as soon as they finished
talking about having to finish the game
they started 26 years ago finish it
we're gonna finish that game finish the
game it'll all go away but if we finish
the game it'll all go away any time guys
listen I know you're upset but I kind of
feel we should finish the game
forget about lions and spiders and vines
because you're about to be hunted by
more serious stuff like unresolved
childhood issues last time I played this
game it ruined my life bullying literal
death fears about your own inadequacy
that manifest as mass shooters
and tons of PTSD something screams then
you and you hope to god - you're not
desert well this is so much darker than
I remembered
my parents are dead to watch romance
balloon between Bonnie Hunt and Robin
Williams just don't think too hard about
it because she's an adult and he's still
mentally a child and real at the happy
ending where all the damage is reversed
but definitely don't think too hard
about that cuz 26 years of life on Earth
got a race because some kids finally
beat a game you know I kind of like my
life but cool very happy for you Bonnie
so strapped in for a film that finally
cracked the code for being a good movie
about a game face it on a made-up game
from a book filled with characters you
actually care about and always cast
Robin Williams then I missed that guy
starring Peter man twin wolf
Kirsten Dunston checks in dollar store
Halloween decorations the reason that's
needed a reboot not a remake vine stars
BB driver Audrey - the Bad Lieutenant
Disney's Jungle Cruise Andy circuses
worst work and the NRA
you'll have to fill out these or I could
fill this out
[Music]
the Jungle Book the game the movie
whatever happened to the helpful kind
hobo Trobe we should bring that one back
yeah you're gonna freeze out there Oh
BBA to be bait take your best shot
chrome dome you can hide but you cannot
hide
muffin button bubbles make me angry
those who believe in telekinesis raise
my hand